well sadly as we learn more about the
lead-up to this horrible mass shooting
another one yeah not the one in texas
not the one we're now up to the one in
highland park illinois as we learn more
about it and we learn more about the
shooter
we learn
that yet another one of these often
repeated phrases from the more guns in
more places american right wing
is meaningless it is worth absolutely
nothing to us
we have now learned that the shooter
legally bought the guns used in the mass
shooting
after
becoming known to police and police
taking a number of knives from the
eventual shooter
the right loves to say listen we can't
take rights away but if there are
specific people
known to police
believed to be dangerous we need some
kind of system to prevent them from
getting guns but we can't take away too
many rights either and we don't we
shouldn't do anything about guns in
general well we had that here and yet
still able to legally buy firearms let's
get into the new york times article that
explains this highland park suspect was
known to police bought guns legally the
man accused of killing seven and
wounding dozens of others in a shooting
that terrorized the fourth of july
parade had been investigated by the
local police before
officers had responded in 2019 after
someone reported that he had tried to
kill himself and they came to his home a
few months later seizing a knife
collection after a family member
reported he had pledged to quote kill
everyone
they they knew about him
still in the years since the man was
able to legally buy several guns in
illinois including a high-powered rifle
that officials said was used in the
attack on monday
tuesday he was charged with seven counts
of first-degree murder
the details of the prior police visits
raised questions about whether the
illinois authorities missed
opportunities to use their relatively
strict firearms laws to block his gun
purchases and about whether a newly
newly signed federal gun law might have
made a difference
had it been in force earlier in a
statement the illinois state police
defended the decision to grant him a
permit to own a gun which he applied for
in december 2019. the police said he
appeared to have prepared for weeks to
attack the parade on monday morning had
used a fire escape to climb atop a
downtown business to fire dozens of
rounds from a high-powered rifle into
the crowd he escaped by discarding his
rifle blending into the crowd wearing
women's clothing
um
eventually they they got him as we all
know
so you know again we can go back and
forth this is just it's a circular
firing squad and it's almost you know
weird to use the term firing squad
proverbially when we're talking about a
literal mass shooting here but
we engage in the same pointless circles
here in the united states with this
stuff
well people need their rights
but in some cases we might be okay
slightly restricting if only on a
temporary basis after some kind of
investigation even though it's kind of
denying people due process
to limit people's ability to legally get
firearms
um
but do we actually enforce those laws
well not really and then joe biden wants
to do something and so do democrats and
republicans don't want to take away
rights but they're willing to do it but
the bill barely does anything anyway but
had it been enforced maybe it would have
prevented
we need a systemic re we need a rewrite
this would be like if you have a script
for a film and one person says they want
to tweak a little bit of the dialogue
and eventually you come to realize we've
got to throw it out and rebuild this
thing from the ground up
when other countries look at the united
states and i know the right-wingers
don't care the right-wingers now the
thing they love saying is
we fought a war to separate from europe
from england
why would we care what other countries
think about us now why do we care what
what england thinks about what's going
on here we it doesn't matter we we
fought to get away from them okay
the world looks at what's happening
and they see these piecemeal fringe
discussions and by fringe i mean just
dealing with the fringes the edges of
the debate
well maybe
uh if you call and you say i think
they're dangerous guys if you're under
25 should you even be able to buy any
kind of rifles i mean that's one of my
one of the points on my 10 to 12 point
proposal if you're under 25 to get any
firearm shouldn't you need
community letters of support from adults
who say i have no concerns with this
person having a firearm
so again i know that people love to say
well
this one provision wouldn't have done
anything in this particular case
right but if you look at my list which
is i didn't come up with the points
these are points that have been floating
around of 10 to 12 ideas to limit mass
shootings to prevent mass shootings
four five or even six of them could have
directly impacted this particular
shooter having had the knives seized
because people were worried he would
kill everyone should have disqualified
him from legally buying firearms oh but
sir that's not due process guys look at
the situation we have in this country
um under 25 straight up shouldn't even
be able to get some of these types of
weapons
would have had it but so i could go on
these things can make a difference we
haven't even tried them we tried the
assault weapons ban in the 90s and it
did reduce
the number frequency and severity of
mass shootings to some degree now some
will say well was it statistically
significant okay that's one of 10 or 12
provisions that i've put together
we have supposedly i mean listen do we
really believe doors are going to solve
the problem of outdoor parade mass
shootings do we really believe securing
fire escapes is going to solve the issue
of shootings in a movie theater we need
systemic change
very few
of those in positions of power are
willing to really do it talking about
republicans here um and you know we can
keep talking about doors and ceilings
and
walls and windows all we want
uh it's not gonna make a difference big
picture so that's where we are police
knew about him they seized his knives
they were worried he was a danger to
himself and others and then he went and
legally bought guns and did what he did
on monday that's where we are
failed and disgraced former fox news
host bill o'reilly
lost his mind
over minorities after the highland park
shooting on monday you have to see this
video clip let me set up what's going on
with bill o'reilly who by the way
seems even more unhinged than i remember
him when he was on his fox news show
the governor of illinois pritzker held a
press conference after the shooting
and um
one of the things that bill o'reilly
took from that is
democrats and the left
only care about these types of shootings
because the perpetrators aren't
minorities but when you look at
gang violence drug crime violence etc
it's minorities and so democrats don't
want to talk talk about it now the funny
thing about this as we look at the clip
is in saying this bill o'reilly's
reasoning is completely flawed and i'll
tell you why in a moment but he's sort
of admitting the mass shooters are
almost exclusively young white men right
i mean he's basically saying the
demographics of the gang violence don't
interest democrats
by definition he's saying the
demographics of the mass shooters are
different and we know that they are it's
mostly young white men in the united
states okay so here's bill o'reilly
completely losing his mind saying
democrats don't want to deal with
shootings when it's minorities doing the
shooting o'reilly at his most disheveled
and unhinged you jb are not going to
stop loons and you won't stop
crime drug crime drug gangs because
they're minority gangs that's why you
won't stop them
you phony
you
aid in a bet this murder in chicago
every blanken day by the way again it
was not in chicago they love to do the
chicago thing because they they believe
chicago puts the image in your mind
again
of gang violence or whatever this was in
a swanky suburb
you
don't be sanctimonious with me
so riley having a having a normal one
this is a real get off my lawn moment
and i've spoken about this so many times
preventing individual single shootings
when specific people are being targeted
like you see in gang violence is number
one most importantly completely
different animal
than what we're talking about with mass
shootings in terms of his causes and
it's in terms of solutions and
prevention and number two
it's it is really difficult to prevent
individual violence
even in some cases when you eliminate
the guns although you do sort of
dissuade people you make them have to
maybe use a more personal tool like a
knife or whatever it doesn't mean we
don't try so let's just think it through
and again when we talk about deaths at
the hands of guns we have three
categories that we're concerned with and
these are no particular order you have
gun suicides
you have sort of individual gun
homicides which includes
disgruntled uh of spouses it includes uh
you know hit men it includes gang
violence drug
deals gone wrong that type of thing
and then you've got your mass shooters
these are three different things
the causes are different
the potential solutions are different it
it's they're just different things
consider
if a disgruntled psychopathic ex-spouse
wants to kill his girlfriend and i say
his girlfriend or his ex-wife because
it's almost always a man doing it just
the way it is
the type of policy we're talking about
on mass shootings is mostly not going to
do that now if you make it really
difficult to even get a handgun
the ex the disgruntled ex-spouse will
say well i'm going to do it with a knife
or i'm going to do it with a baseball
bat or whatever it's more it's more
personal and up close so they may not do
it but it is a different type of thing
um when it when a gang member member
says i've been disrespected by this
person and i've now got to get get back
at them
you know limiting rifles so that they
end up with a handgun or even in some
cases limiting hand they if they're
determined to go after a particular
individual they're going to do it to
some degree maybe they won't kill them
separately
here we're talking about mass shootings
where you need certain tools and certain
provisions to dissuade you make guns
harder to get or at least you make the
deadlier guns harder to get well then
this particular shooter might have
killed fewer people that would be good
we want zero people killed but killing
one instead of seven is better
injuring one instead of dozens is better
you make the ammunition really expensive
well maybe he wouldn't have had as many
bullets would have reduced the lethality
of it you put an age limit on rifles
well he might have been relegated to a
handgun
the number of people he'll kill with a
handgun from a rooftop is probably a low
lower number than what he was able to do
it's just different and so bill
o'reilly's saying you just don't want to
go after black people who commit crime
that's what o'reilly's saying
and it's absurd and these are different
types of of incidents and we should deal
with all of them
but the way you reduce gun violence has
components that are very different
when it comes to i'm sorry the way you
reduce gang gun violence has elements
that are very different than when we
talk about these typical mass shootings
and so we don't say one is a bigger or
smaller problem or whatever we say we
want to deal with multiple problems the
fact that treating um uh
you know a damaged knee
is done differently than cancer
doesn't mean we ignore either it just
means we take different approaches
that's all that's all that we're saying
and o'reilly i mean look at this guy
completely out of his gourd completely
out of his cord has lost it all right
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at deepakman we'll take a quick
break and be back with so much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is a community
funded program what community well you
you're part of the community if you
listen to this podcast if you watch the
show on youtube or listen on one of our
radio affiliates or even watch on our
television affiliates free speech tv on
directv and dish you're part of the
community and i would love for you to
support our work by signing up at
joinpakman.com it's very cheap it comes
with great benefits including commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
every day
five or six hours earlier than we
published the show to everybody as well
as the world famous bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad well call it what it
is but it's an extra show every single
day
just for our members you can sign up at
joinpacman.com
you can use the coupon code if you want
don't feel obligated but it's available
big voting 22. all one word all
lowercase big voting 22 and you'll get a
beautiful discount
well as i've been saying for about a
month and a half now
if there are going to be serious
criminal charges against the upper
echelon of the trump circle
i believe they are more likely to come
from the georgia investigation remember
that's the one where trump wanted votes
i need 11 000 votes give me a break that
one then from what's going on with the
january 6 committee that's my opinion
now it could be wrong and indeed we are
getting a sign that there could be
trouble
in paradise
rudy giuliani trump's former lawyer
republican senator lindsey graham
as well as trump's former lawyer john
eastman have been subpoenaed in the
georgia it's actually fulton county
grand jury probe
rolling stone rights the fulton county
grand jury's probe appears to be closing
in on the former president who pressured
georgia's top election officials to find
the votes i need 11 000 votes give me a
break needed to overturn the election
um they have slapped a bevy of subpoenas
on several figures tied to trump
including rudy giuliani
lindsey graham
john eastman john eastman's that very
outrageous lawyer who wrote the plan for
how pence could potentially overturn the
results and then was advised to get a
criminal lawyer
by eric hirschberg cleta mitchell
kenneth chesbro and jenna ellis all of
which were involved in trump's scheme to
overturn the election also received
subpoenas so too did senator lindsey
graham
the atlanta journal constitution notes
giuliani testified before georgia
lawmakers three times following the 2020
election and that the ludicrous
unfounded claims about election fraud
during that testimony has drawn the
interest of the grand jury remember rudy
was flying around the country
with flatulence and covid i'm not it's
just it's what it is i'm just telling
you what it is
um doing hearings where if i recall
correctly no one was under oath like
almost ever or maybe ever
and um he was making a fool out of
himself he was making a fool out of
trump it was crazy so rudy is the target
of a subpoena lindsey graham allegedly
called georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger to ask if he had the power
to toss out legally cast absentee
ballots uh so uh lindsay is being sucked
into it
and um
john eastman as well the subpoenas which
were issued yesterday come as the grand
jury has been hearing testimony from a
parade of witnesses
so there's a couple different things
going on here that i think are important
to
consider
first of all
when i look at lindsey graham
lindsay to me seems like the exact type
of guy who will throw anybody under the
bus to save himself
rudy seems like the type of guy who
others throw under the bus and so far
that's the way it's worked out lindsay
has flip-flopped a dozen times now on is
trump good or bad
what was the deal with the 2020 election
it you might remember very early on the
morning of january 7th after midnight
roughly maybe just before midnight
lindsay gave this speech on the floor of
that house or senate don't remember
where they were convened at the time and
said it's time for it to end the
election is over and people looked and
said oh good what a mature guy
but then he walks that back and he says
the regularities this that the other
thing so lindsay is the prototypical guy
of i'll say whatever i need to say right
now to save my own ass
rudy has just been getting slapped
around by everybody trump yeah they they
all it's
and so everybody is kind of playing
their role
um
the question about john eastman is an
interesting one eastman
he wrote this
seven point or however many points there
were a plan
for how pence could
send the election back to the states
but he seemed to acknowledge based on
testimony given to the january 6
committee i think that he sort of knew
it was bogus and then he was advised to
get a criminal lawyer because what he
was sort of suggesting
is arguably against the law uh very
clearly seems to be against the law so i
don't know what the direction will be
there now there have been many people
saying are they going to fight these
subpoenas are they going to ignore these
subpoenas well they'll do everything
they can to delay their appearances
but
contempt of court is different than
contempt of congress not showing up when
the january 6 committee wants you to
show up is one thing and that we've seen
some criminal referrals but not showing
up when you're subpoenaed by a court is
a different thing so my expectation is
they'll delay the appearances as much as
possible
and then they'll show up and
assert their fifth amendment right uh to
avoid self-incrimination
and um
i i don't know that you're really going
to see them in serious legal trouble
but we're going to follow it now uh the
one other aspect of this
is
people have been asking about
extradition
my understanding is that within the
within the us states extradite like if
uh you know rudy i don't know where rudy
lives now maybe he's in new york maybe
he's in dc i'm not sure
if um georgia calls new york and says
you gotta extradite rudy he's in
contempt of court
my understanding is new york does it
that new york will do it but uh we will
allow other lawyers to weigh in on that
as well hey this is another one of the
sort of i mean like i would i guess i
would use the word unintended
consequences
but maybe it's predictable consequences
doctors
who
are now being presented with pregnant
women with cancer
are increasingly skittish
about treating the women
for fear that they could end up arrested
as a result of anti-abortion laws and we
have to think this through that this is
kind of like the the logic of it and if
you're interested in this there's a good
article in business insider uh pregnant
cancer patients may die because doctors
fear treating them could now count as
illegal abortion experts say so here's
the gist of it pregnant woman has cancer
you treat her for cancer as a cancer
doctor
it doesn't go well and she dies or
the stress of the treatment and the
cancer while under your care causes a
miscarriage
there are states criminalizing
miscarriage and with roe v wade
overturned
those laws are now active in many states
this goes beyond just pregnant cancer
patients any patient coming to coming
into the emergency room and pregnant
doctors may be saying do i need a lawyer
here do i need a politician here to
figure out
what if the treatment they need could
cause a miscarriage
oh but david there's exceptions to all
this stuff if you look at the laws in
most of these states the exceptions are
potentially meaningless
unless i mean listen we don't every
state has different laws but you are
increasingly having a situation here
where professional medical professionals
who know what the right course of
treatment is based on medicine
are now being second guessed by
politicians with an agenda tied into the
criminal justice system and if it means
jail time if a politician gets their way
if x y or z happens as a result direct
or indirect of the treatment you provide
to a pregnant woman be it cancer or any
other kind of emergent situation in an
emergency room
are doctors really going to be providing
the best care in those situations it
seems that the answer is no so i will
link to this article i would i would
encourage you to check it out
and um
you you could end up in a situation
where doctors say
i'm not comfortable administering
chemo
which you need
uh because you're pregnant and it could
end up with me
in legal hot water now
i i am sure that the right would say
that is not the intent
of these laws
but as we have learned many times the
intent and the consequences
are two different things and in many
cases could be completely divorced from
each other so
predictable
horrifying
the united states of america in some
states in a post-rovi world era in 2022.
i want to briefly look at an appearance
that radical repugnant republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green made
and at a religious event i guess it's
called flashpoint live
uh marjorie taylor green showed up
with a big cross necklace just to just
to remind you how deeply spiritual she
is and she said defiantly
president trump won the state of georgia
this is a religious event and it's just
a reminder of the um
inextricably linked
christian dominionism christian
nationalism and trumpist ideology
despite trump personally not being a
religious guy
okay so marge we got i told you about
some things i wanted to ask about but
let's get right let's dive right into
the whole election integrity issue in
georgia right what do these people need
to do about that
well you know that's a big issue
if you're so i've heard
how many people are from georgia i'm
assuming everyone
i i love this by the way absolutely love
it okay so
we all know that elections are of course
serious i mean i don't know about you
guys but i know that president trump won
in the state of georgia right
standing ovation other than one guy
walking around with some kind of bucket
um
completely insane completely unhinged
and again there's nothing in principle
which makes it so that if you're an
evangelical christian dominionist
nationalist type
you have to believe that the guy who
lost actually won like you could just be
a christian dominionist and be like no
trump lost
but this movement has blended these two
things together in a very disturbing way
next clip marjorie taylor green says aoc
has the intelligence of less than a
kindergartner they want you driving
electric vehicles ladies and gentlemen
they
worship the climate and they very much
want to and this is the entire democrat
party they want to pass the green new
deal
well let me tell you
boo the problem with the green new deal
other than the fact aoc who has the
intelligence of less than a
kindergartner by the way
that's a big applause line for this
group
it's true i work with her i know
but anyways the green new deal the
problem with the green yo deal other
than the fact that it brings carbon down
to zero which doesn't make sense because
what are trees and plants like
this is so stupid so she's like listen
trees and plants like carbon dioxide the
trees and the plants breathe in the
carbon dioxide and they spit out the
oxygen we bring in the oxygen spit out
the carbon dioxide now this is stupid
for two it's probably stupid for ten
different reasons but as i'm sure many
of you know the issue is balance the
issue is balance we have a planet we
have a world as donald trump likes to
say and we need
the oxygen and the co2 to be in balance
the issue is we are overwhelming the
planet with co2 more than the trees and
the plants can deal with uh conversely
um when when she talks about
listen okay you you get it we don't it's
very stupid she's uh throwing stones
while in a glass house then she calls
the left godless and i love my state
i've lived here i was born here i grew
up here just like many of you and there
is no way
that we are going to hand over our home
state of georgia to the radical godless
left
what does that even mean hand over the
state i mean biden won that's what you
can't really change that now try as they
might
um
she uh marjorie taylor greene is still
talking about brad raffensberger the
secretary of state who i mean listen for
all of his faults refused to just flip
the election because trump wanted it
flipped
and then we have someone running and
this is where we're all going to have a
little trouble because i'm still having
trouble we have another woman it's like
a trifecta everyone another woman
running for secretary of state against
brad raffensberger
[Music]
right
well you know i supported jody heiss
jody heiss is an absolute lunatic
extremist who we've talked about before
so still talking about brad
raffensberger greene warns that stacy
abrams is a major threat coming in
november she's the democratic
gubernatorial nominee i would love for
stacey abrams to be the next governor of
georgia we have a major threat
coming in november
and and i'm going to say there's three
of them and i don't think there's enough
people talking about this right one of
them is named stacy abrams
exactly exactly
and you know what she's actually right
there is a threat coming from stacy
abrams in the sense that she threatens
to overturn republican rule in georgia
and it would be delightful
really important race to get involved in
if you're thinking well do i want to get
involved in oz versus fetterman and
pennsylvania that's a good one do i want
there's lots of important races that
could make a difference
georgia having a democratic governor
could be a huge deal in 2024. we'll have
these clips on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show back right
after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show today
we're going to be speaking with jeffrey
mandel who's president and lead counsel
at law forward the firm that filed the
landmark lawsuit against the fraudulent
2020 electors in wisconsin uh really
great having you on i appreciate your
time
thanks so much david it's great to be
here so just to get everybody kind of up
to speed we saw attempts at this fake
elector scam in a number of different
states arizona's one place where it made
a lot of news
the concept was even though joe biden
won
what if we we meaning typically some
republicans what if we just send
republican electors to say we're giving
our electoral votes to donald trump
anyway
that's the gist of it is that right
that is the gist of it it requires us
stepping back and sort of thinking back
to schoolhouse rock and our basic
understanding of civics
we all think that every fourth november
we go to the polls and we vote for a
candidate for president right people say
did you vote for biden or did you vote
for trump but in reality you're voting
for a slate of electors who will
represent your state in the electoral
college it is not the popular vote it is
that electoral college vote that chooses
the president and so what we had was
seven states
where even though the popular vote
said that the electors pledged to joe
biden and kamala harris would represent
that state in the electoral college
nonetheless electors who were pledged to
donald trump and mike pence chose to
meet and submit papers claiming that
they were actually the valid
qualified and duly elected electors for
their state so in wisconsin for example
what that meant was we had 10
individuals and as you note they're
mostly republican party bigwigs um who
decided that they knew better than 3.3
million of their neighbors a record 3.3
million wisconsinites voted in 2020 and
these 10 people decided that they didn't
care what those other 3.3 million people
thought they were going to take it upon
themselves to hijack wisconsin's
participation in choosing the next
president
now
when we talk about the january 6th
committee there's an investigation
happening in georgia etc the question of
criminality of some of the different
things that were attempted is often
brought up to be clear you have filed a
lawsuit that seeks damages the
criminality question is a different one
when it comes to these schemes is that
right
that's right and i do think that at
least here under wisconsin state law
and around the country under federal law
i think that there is a likelihood that
many of these people committed crimes
and could be prosecuted and potentially
put in jail but what we are filing is a
civil lawsuit that seeks civil remedies
and will be a way of trying to learn
more about exactly what did happen here
in wisconsin and how it worked because a
civil lawsuit comes with discovery the
opportunity to see documents to take
depositions and have testimony i'm
trying to think back you there was this
kind of circus tour that went around the
country that involved rudy giuliani and
jenna ellis and sometimes sydney powell
and others
did did that circus go through wisconsin
around the same time that the fake
elector scam was being kind of
conceived
well the circus never came fully to town
here in wisconsin um you know rudy
giuliani for example to my knowledge
never came
to wisconsin we did have one of sydney
powell's uh kraken lawsuits yes
conspiracy theories here in wisconsin
and what's interesting about that i mean
there are lots of things that are
interesting about that but one of the
things that's interesting about that is
the plaintiff that sidney powell
represented in that lawsuit is one of
the fraudulent electors right um here in
wisconsin so all of this is tied
together and so the circus came to town
through the courts but it never came to
town with the with the full media
entourage so in terms of your lawsuit i
mean what are you alleging what are the
damages who who was uh damaged so to
speak
sure so we represent um three plaintiffs
two of them were actually the
among the valid electors for joe biden
and kamala harris
one of them is a voter who feels
strongly that these people tried to
disenfranchise her and steal the value
of her vote by going against the will of
the voters and what we're doing is we're
using some old established common law
ideas to try to get at this conduct
fundamentally the problem is
nobody ever thought
that someone would try something as
audacious as what these fake electors
did in these seven states so there is no
law that says you can't do that because
we don't pass laws that tell people not
to do things that nobody would ever
imagine someone would do
and that has led to this challenge of
saying no matter who we talk to when we
explain what the fraudulent collectors
did
everyone says oh that can't be right
that can't be legal um that offends my
most basic sense of fair play and civic
understanding of democracy right
but there isn't a specific law so what
we've done is we've taken some very old
principles from the common law and said
that we think that these fit so one of
them is public nuisance right our
election system and our democracy is a
finely calibrated and and somewhat
fragile
structure that is for the public good
and there is a long-standing idea that
if
if if i take private action that harms
the public good
um someone can try to stop me using a
doctrine that says that i'm creating a
nuisance to the public for my own
benefit but everyone else's detriment so
we're using that theory uh we're using a
theory of civil conspiracy
that these
ten electors and thus far we've also
named two lawyers who assisted them and
we might need to add more people as as
we find out who else was involved right
the january sixth committee recently
made quite clear that senator johnson
seems to be involved
but that these people conspired
to break the law whether they ultimately
did break the law right that's sort of
the criminal question but the fact that
they were trying to break the law that
they were trying to convince congress
to take these papers that in itself we
think is actionable and there is a long
long standing idea um and i apologize
for the latin but it goes under the name
of quoranto
this is a writ an order
that you could go to for hundreds of
years to courts if you were supposed to
serve in a public office but someone
else was occupying that office and
keeping you out of it and so we are
bringing a a a claim
for such an order on behalf of the
actual electors that these other people
have tried to usurp that office and by
saying we trump fraudulent electors
we're the real electors they are
implicitly saying that the biden
electors are liars
and are are not the real electors and so
we're also bringing a claim under under
that theory have the um have the have
the fraudulent electors had to
personally lawyer up as a result of this
at this point
they have so um they've all hired
counsel
and we're in those early stages of
lawsuits as you know david you know
litigation can be kind of slow yes so
we're in the early stages of the the
lawyers sort of maneuvering we filed in
state court they would rather be federal
court which is not where this case
belongs and so we're in the process of
bringing it back to state court
what kind of uh damages and restitution
are you seeking here
so we're seeking a number of things um
first we're seeking a clear and uh
unambiguous order from a court that what
happened here was improper and unlawful
and it should never happen again
second we are seeking an order that
would prohibit any of these people from
ever being involved with the electoral
college in wisconsin again because it
seems to me that they have abused the
privilege of being part of our civic
fabric and they should they should not
have that opportunity again
um
third
we are seeking um
deterrence we want accountability and we
want deterrence we never want to see
this happen again and so we are seeking
punitive damages for the fact that these
folks deliberately interfered in the
legal rights of the real electors and
under wisconsin law those punitive
damages could be up to two hundred
thousand dollars for each of the
defendants
have you been in touch with potential uh
with lawyers that are potentially
looking at doing this in other states
where these schemes were hatched
we've certainly uh we've certainly had
some conversations and some outreach it
is my hope i really believe that both
accountability and deterrence are
essential so this doesn't happen again
and so it is my hope that we will see uh
cases like this in all of the states one
of the big questions is
if whoever had followed through on this
like if these electors had gotten on a
plane or you know what whatever the the
real attempt was a bonafide attempt
what would have happened like could
could they have said no we we believe
that trump gets these votes
and then what would have happened i mean
john eastman wrote this memo of how what
pence could do he's now in legal
jeopardy himself he's had to lawyer up
the fbi recently seized his phone you
know he's got his fair share of problems
for even suggesting this framework but
there's this question of like if they
both show up then then what would have
happened
well i mean the reality is we came a lot
closer to that than than we'd like to
think because i think your intuition
that the electoral college happens in
washington is a common one but that's
actually not right
the electoral college happens in each
state's capital at the same time on the
same date and so
when these fraudulent electors met in
madison on december 14th of 2020 and
they and they signed these papers
claiming to be the real electors and
when that happened in arizona and in
georgia and in michigan and in nevada
and in pennsylvania and in new mexico
that that was the thing they submitted
these papers that's the act in other
words like the real electors did it on
that day and the fake electors did and
then so at that point it's it's it but
they've both done it
that's absolutely right and it really
all came down to to then vice president
pence um if he had followed john
eastman's uh wishes
and been willing to credit those votes
then we would have seen
chaos we would have seen how congress
reacted uh we've seen uh almost
certainly litigation
but we really would have been in a
constitutional crisis um it is to uh to
mr pence's
credit
that he refused to go along with that
and recognize that uh in our in our
democracy the will of the voters really
is sacrosanct yeah tom hartman radio
host tom hartman has an interesting
twitter thread from in the last week it
might be a few days ago where he kind of
outlines
what this could look like in 2024
with the difference that
there is a move to accept different
electors and that although we all
intuitively know that's not right it's
not what's supposed to happen it would
be a violation of the will of the people
all of the things that you've said
it's not so cut and dry that it
obviously fails that it could get pretty
complicated and dicey for a period of
time
it absolutely could and one of the ways
that that could happen
is if state courts that um
support the losing candidate
wanted to um sort of muddy the waters
in in wisconsin for example the
we had a partial recount or president
trump's campaign asked for a recount in
in the madison area in milwaukee
and then when they didn't like the
results of that recount because it
actually showed that that biden won by
more votes um they they they filed a
lawsuit as they are entitled to do to
challenge the results of the recount and
that case went up to the wisconsin
supreme court the wisconsin supreme
court took unprecedented actions i don't
think this had ever happened before the
case came in on a friday afternoon the
electoral college was meeting on monday
at noon and that's a statutory deadline
and so the court had people brief late
at night on friday night they held oral
argument
by zoom on saturday and they issued a
full opinion um
with all of its reasoning and everything
on monday morning so that they would
have given the final word on the
election results in wisconsin before the
electoral college met
but imagine i mean mr eastman's
arguments would be much stronger if the
court had not done that if there was
still a question about who the legal
winner in a state was
then there is a much
better argument for these dueling slates
and you really have questions then about
how congress is supposed to resolve this
or what they're supposed to do so we
could
with what we've learned from 2020 we
could imagine in 2024 a number of actors
uh taking making specific decisions to
try to
leave more flexibility for congress or
the vice president or make this uglier
and harder in ways that are really
really um dangerous to our democracy
very very scary but uh one piece of what
what is being done uh is this lawsuit
and we've been speaking with jeffrey
mandel president and lead counsel at law
forward
thanks so much for talking to me today
and explaining what you're what you're
doing
thanks david for having me it's a
pleasure i appreciate your attention to
this and i hope we can come back and
update you as it moves forward
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
all right i have a couple of quick
stories to briefly talk about this is an
interesting one it it is now appearing
that donald trump has been desperate to
appear on joe rogan's podcast and that
joe rogan has turned him down we're
going to look at a clip of
rogan himself explaining this there's a
daily beast article joe rogan reveals
he's rejected trump multiple times for
interview rogan recently declared his
support for ron desantis on tuesday he
said he's absolutely no trump fan and
has no desire to assist him in any way
shape or form
this was on a podcast with host lex
friedman and rogan talked about how
weird the trump era is going to be in
retrospect some of the reasons rogan
cited are not ones i agree with uh but
that's okay let's listen to what joe joe
rogan had to say about uh trump wanting
to be on his show by the way i'm not a
trump supporter in any way shape or form
i've had the opportunity to have him on
my show more than once i've said no
every time i don't want to help him i'm
not interested in helping him now one
interesting question
is
whether such an interview
would be a good interview for someone
like joe rogan and his show because when
you think about the rogan format which
is
uh three hour conversations and i've
been on for two of them on a show
um
often in depth
and sort of flighty
non-sequential thinking
is not very conducive to those types of
conversations and this is what trump
does you ask him about one thing and you
say hey you know what what's the deal
with though you i heard you like fast
food
yeah well you know i uh kfc you know
they make it's they make a tremendous
bird and uh but the thing is you know
the democrats and radical joe biden they
want to control everything not only did
he lose he wants to take away burgers
and i mean we just you just can't have
it and i said i would fix it i would fix
all of it i would fix tray
you know it's it's not he's not even
really able to have that type of a
conversation and you know the
speculation of trump uh with adult adhd
or whatever i think the guy just has no
idea what's going on in any serious
depth with any topic i think that's
really the explanation and trump would
ramble on and interrupt and interject
about the election stolen or whatever so
from like a conversational standpoint
i don't know how trump does
a three-hour conversation with rogan
that's not a praise or a criticism of
the format i think it's a great
it's great to have podcasts of all
different formats and the three-hour
conversation is a great format for
people who can do it it doesn't seem to
me that that trump could do it now in
terms of rogan doesn't want to help
trump as i've said before i don't think
there's any
like big mystery
about rogan
i think
rogan admits
he's not the most keyed into politics
and rogan to a degree is a chameleon of
sorts when i was on his show and i
espoused all of my left-wing ideas
joe agreed with almost everything i had
to say and then when he has on you know
whoever from the right
he agrees generally with most of the
things they have to say he's had
disagreements that i've covered with
people like
um
he's had disagreements with ben shapiro
on some things
he's had disagreements with candace
owens you know right-wingers in a sense
and to a degree i think that
what's happening with rogan is
he is um
when it comes to a lot of different
areas he is clearly on the left when you
get into the details i think he
genuinely is
i think
he's also culturally conservative a lot
of the circles he's now in
you know ufc and dana white definite
right wing uh bent there he's now in
texas and reportedly i think has a
relationship with the governor there
greg abbott who's an extreme right
winger he's in this environment where
there's a lot of kind of de facto
right-wing thinking and then like on
desantis i just think he's sort of
confused i don't even think rogan is
aware that desantis stands for the
opposite of most of the things rogan has
espoused support for so i don't think we
need to get into this thing of like
ascribing
uh a significant morality to it i think
politics isn't rogan's main thing
and he finds common ground with almost
anyone he talks to
and while he is socially liberal to a
great degree
he's also in a culturally conservative
environment and that rubs off on him so
interesting for sure how much we glean
from it about anything in particular
other than trump's desperation to get on
rogan's podcast which is interesting uh
is probably not too too much
there's a fascinating docu-series soon
to be released about the trump family i
genuinely am looking forward to this
there's not a lot of stuff like this
that i look forward to the political
playbook was able to exclusively obtain
footage sort of like a two-minute
trailer
from a docu-series about the trump
family and the trump riots
this was produced by alex holder it's
called unprecedented it's a
alex holder is a british filmmaker it's
going to be on discovery plus
let's check out the trailer this is
really really interesting stuff
[Music]
okay do you see this line
[Music]
i'm tired i did uh evangelicals for
trump and i did indian americans for
trump than i did asian pacific yeah
americans for
[Music]
my
trump
the people's president we will make
liberals cry again
i don't think you won't have the water
in the picture right
you can take it
[Music]
so in the family we've done 55 events in
48 hours
[Music]
the campaign basically was a family
operation washing my hands after giving
a bunch of fist bumps you know
is that okay
yeah i must we'll take the table maybe i
should just like makatsu have the like
dog on my lap
can i borrow your dog can i wear a [ __ ]
up
stroking that's why i broke put the
table back and put the water on the
table without the thing on top of it
[Music]
this is a business oh this feels good or
you have to be in it for the right
reasons
this is a fraud
on the american public for the sake of
this country where you get these guys
let's kick some ass
let's win
let's walk down pennsylvania avenue they
threw the damn match
[Music]
you gotta get the roaches out all of
them when you manipulate people that has
consequences
donald trump was able to use his
children as the embodiment of trump the
brand he's an unconventional person he
believes that everything that he's doing
is right how does that look trump has
always looked at his project as a
dynastic one
they have a base they have their own
base people have no idea how hard this
family worked
it's part of my base
[Music]
this is my house
right let's go
do you miss me yet
[Music]
i think this is going to be absolutely
fascinating and to be perfectly honest
the trailer looks like a mockumentary i
mean when you see some of these shots of
the behind the scenes of trump
figuring out how he wants to sit and
whether he wants water next to him or
whatever
it seems like a mockumentary but these
people were in power for four years they
might be in power again and i think it's
going to be an absolutely fascinating
docu-series i'm looking forward to it
we'll review it when it finally comes
out we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
here is our friend juan who sometimes
refers to himself as the troll man
if he's asking the question he asks in
this voicemail genuinely it's actually a
good one let's discuss
hey david what's up it's juan i have a
question
why are you against or discredited
anecdote
a lot of decisions that i make in my
life are based on my experience
my anecdotal experience am i to ignore
that and just guide myself by what 99 of
the population goes through
that doesn't make any sense
anecdotes are important
and people make decisions based on their
experience
why why
should anyone discredit
or not guide themselves by their
anecdotal experience yeah so this is
it's this is a great question
my anecdotes are my experience why
wouldn't i guide myself by that
the first thing is you have to be able
to distinguish when we say something is
anecdotal
we're sort of by definition saying that
it is not representative or it's not a
large enough sample size
guiding oneself by their own experience
is great for example if you've driven to
work the same way every day for a month
and it's taken you no less than 25 20
minutes and no more than 35 minutes okay
it is logical to say based on my
experience
i probably will never take
under 20 minutes to get to work or more
than 35 in 95 of the times i drive to
work but that's not really anecdotal
that's actually a large enough sample
size to be able to say
an anecdote would be you move to a new
city and you say i start a new job
tomorrow today's sunday i'm going to
drive to work to see how long it takes
but it's la
and the oscars are going on that day and
so traffic is crazy and it takes you 90
minutes to do the drive on sunday to
then say well my experience is the drive
took 90 minutes i'm going to plan on 90
minutes tomorrow monday morning
that would be incorrectly making
decisions based on anecdotal experience
personal experience can be anecdotal or
it can be comprehensive anecdotes aren't
useful for causation okay i have a
headache
i eat five lemons and the headache goes
away and i go lemons must cause it must
prevent headaches well headaches usually
go away on their own anyway that one
anecdote doesn't tell me that lemons
cure my headache even though it was my
quote experience it was an anecdotal
experience you really need a
double-blind randomized controlled trial
to look at that and then you also have
to consider that headache is a condition
we have a regression to the mean where
it typically goes away and people go i
no longer have a headache even if you do
nothing anecdotes aren't controlled
they're not representative they're often
a sample size of one or two or you know
they're also not systematically
collected lots of people told me when
they get a cold they make a tea from the
leaves of dostoyevsky novels
they drink it and the cold goes away
within a couple days well it's a biased
group of people who tried something
weird they might be particularly
interested in telling others about it
whereas lots of people get a cold and
they go there's no treatment for it i'm
gonna wait three to five days and then
it'll be gone and they don't mention to
you hey you know what nothing i tried
worked so the cold eventually went away
so these are not systematically
collected anecdotes so
i i hope that what i'm saying is clear
but when juan says what's wrong with
anecdotes anecdotes are my experience
experience can be anecdotal or it can be
comprehensive i'll give you another
example
every day what i do this show
from only my own experience from only my
own experience i'm able to judge
how long is it going to take me to
produce the show today okay and the you
know the show itself is 55 minutes and
then we do a 15 minute bonus show and
whatever that's an hour and 10 minutes
but i know there's breaks and whatever
so i go listen i need just under two
hours to produce the show
it's only based on what i've experienced
but it's not anecdotal in the sense that
it's a comprehensive experience over
years of doing this and it is of
predictive value it's different than if
you say hey david today
you're hosting some other show
and i do it once and it takes me four
hours and i go i guess this show takes
four hours to produce well no it was
your first time doing it you're not
experienced at doing it yet that's the
difference i hope that it's clear we
have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about gavin newsom
2024. we are there's polling now about
gavin newsom 2024. we are going to talk
about gas prices going down in the
united states 21 days in a row
this must be joe biden's doing right i
mean if it's joe biden's fault that the
gas prices went up it must be joe
biden's fault that the gas prices went
down or not we will discuss and we will
also give you the latest with uh
basketball player brittany geiner griner
sorry who has written a letter to joe
biden
asking for help all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com